hey
it's another year it's another call of
duty this year it's called duty infinite
warfare rob you and i have played a
pretty extensive amount of the campaign
as of now have we not yeah we have and
you texted me the other night when we
were both playing and we both had a
weirdly kind of like coincidental
sentiment and a bunch people around the
office or sharing we both said for some
reason it's reminding us of mass effect
and to preface that not obviously in the
RPG mechanics but in the way you kind of
go about the campaign because this is a
pretty drastic departure from call of
duty campaign tradition right it's not
just these linear missions that you're
gonna be following people through you
know your leader you're the captain of
the unsa retribution the ship you're
picking side missions on this star map
that you don't have to do it all but
they're giving you upgrades that are
gonna make you better in the main
missions but when you go up to that star
map and you you're talking to your crew
and you're kind of just talking these
npcs that are littered around you know
the bridge or the you know the crew
quarters or the firing range you can
like kind of interact with them much
like you might in an RPG hubtown it's
pretty cool but then like you actually
get to decide to go on these side
missions or not and what are your
impression so far the campaign as far
like how it compares how they're called
duty I think you nailed it there are
these really nice transitions and segues
going back to and from your ship
essentially going to the armory
interacting with the person who is in
charge of your weapons you know for
something where you you're getting
thrown into a mission it's a nice little
touch to have that interaction with your
crew because you are the captain of this
entire crew the ship like you you you
want to care about them and that's the
best way to do it is to walk around and
see people working and people saluting
you going back to your crew quarters
maybe you had a rough time like out on
Saturn you're like I need a minute like
you can you don't have to get right into
it you can take some time to kind of
walk around calm your nerves it was a
really tough mission whatever you want
to say maybe you know you could you your
computer it's that's the coolest is it
again to emphasize like the transitions
of this game you sit on your computer
you pull your modern front of you and
you know you do some research you got a
board behind you of like top enemy uh
assassination missions that you can look
at yeah the deck of cards were like the
aces a kid Harrington's character and
everything right uh it's just it really
reminds me of the idea of mass effect
two of like you know you you have those
I mean again you're not making dialogue
choices but you're getting bits of
character and Inter character conflicts
between other people in your crew you're
seeing that in game in gameplay on the
bridge you just you're you're
consistently in this role it is it is to
say the very least it's super immersive
you know I get stage fright racer you
got feelings Ethan I do lieutenant I do
I carry the bringing of a human farmer
holy [ __ ] are you serious no ma'am there
are so many words I hate using that
developers use as buzzwords now like
immersive like seamless and lived in but
that game exemplifies all of these right
because you know you do a main mission
you go to the star map you say all right
let's go to Titan you leave the star map
and you leave the bridge you go down to
the armory you pick your loadout they
have a recommended one or you can do
your own then you walk down to the
hangar you get into your jackal you
actually like get the Boosters ready and
then you get to hear the countdown from
like the the person in charge a hangar
and then you just fly out then it goes
into like this quick not even a cutscene
write this like bookending kind of like
a little cinematic where your Jackals
leaving and you see salt you're like
right hand what persons like other
jackal behind you and then you go and
like usually instead of ending the
mission once you you know if you're in a
jackal dogfight with your ship you'll
either land on an enemy ship rather than
it cut to black and you end up on there
it'll be you land there and then at the
end of a mission it won't just cut to
black and have you back in your quarters
you'll go back and land on the
retribution get docked and then have a
conversation with salt again before you
go back up to the quarters and then you
go into this crew's quarters where
they're just hanging out playing like
pool i think but then there's a
broadcast about what you just waited
just did yeah and then you go into the
quarters and then someone will say like
Ethan this character than me and you
were both like falling in love with for
all intensive purposes like he's a robot
right but then there's a certain part
where like he go through this like a ton
of [ __ ] and they're asking like ray as
your character like where's Ethan and
he's like oh I gave him some mandatory
rnr like he gave that's how much like
they care about this robot this like non
he's sentient being because like he's so
personable that he they think he needs
are and are like to get like his nerves
back in place he know he's fine yeah
like that character in general almost
reminds me of like a World War two
you know he's the guy in the squad
that's like I once a pet but I feel like
that would be demeaning for Ethan
because yeah I got very much a person he
can like pulverize people's heads oh
yeah uh but you you kind of gathered the
sense of squad and everyone you know has
like that mascot almost like Giovanni
Ribisi Alphonse no afonso vin diesel
from saving private ryan or shifty
powers from band of brothers yeah just
that like like wholeheartedly optimistic
person throughout the time like we don't
finish the campaign so I have no idea
was gonna happen but I'm kind of like
I'm loving Ethan so far what's the
Navy's official policy for a convoy send
in the marine as for you can see you all
like to swim a little dizzy shirt
to touch back on actually said atlantan
to think about landing on an aircraft
carrier or your space ship carrier is
initially that sounds very you know
linear like you told you after every
mission whatever you land on it not
every time if you're in a dogfight
around your carrier after you just did a
ground assault mission the game will say
if you don't to my understanding cuz
I've only done this about like four or
five times but if I cannot eliminate all
the targets in the air someone on the
bridge will play Captain we need to
leave right now you have ten seconds to
land your craft or we're all gonna die
before you go like take do a light speed
jump right so they're asking you to do
it and that's pretty intense so there is
a consequence to like these different
beats of what seemed to be and could be
repetitive side missions kinda have like
a different choice and in everyone and I
would even argue like that's what I
think bits of mass effect 3 actually
kind of fell short because I remember
like two and one there there was more of
that transition I'm going to a planet I
get to explore initial initially and in
three I remember it's just a it's just
like a loading screen of your ship
mm-hmm you know what I mean and that was
something that I kind of missed from
this from the 2nd mass effect in this
game like holy god I don't even know
when there are loading screams the one
comparison i made like if you're into
movies is Birdman or like rope Alfred
Hitchcock's movies those movies that
they intentionally shot them to look
like there were no cuts or no edits and
I mean it's like it's weird to compare
it to an ER to a movie but like it
really does feel like that kind of like
it's this one over R like overarching
experience that doesn't feel like it's
divided it feels like a singular thing
and it's like really like impactful the
way they did it and it's weird that
we're talking to call duty game right
now which is like perennially chapter
chapter chapter you know like set-pieces
the seppies are still here very much so
but it's just all these lights the
spectacle whereas now it's the structure
is so engrossing and i really can't wait
to keep playing you know there's zombies
and multiplayer but for the first time I
think I'm actually more excited for the
campaign the more I play it and I'm
really excited for how much infinite
warfare is surprising us
thanks Rob thank you
harness tall for 21 guys